conservatives will argue lower taxes are  good for everybody increases economic  growth increases Prosperity Rising tide  lifts all boats they'll say it with  regulation reducing regulation is good  for everybody economic growth prosperity  it's great the truth is it's a scam  those very policies they they do  particularly in the short term increase  profits for corporations in the wealthy  but they externalize the burden of the  pollution that is created or the low  wages that are paid which then we all  have our taxes go to social welfare  programs to support people who rightly  need those programs because the  corporations are paying low wages they  claim it's good for everybody their  economic policy is good for everybody  but it leads to Cuts in Social Services  or increased spending on Social Services  higher health care costs lower wages for  workers we all pay for it